here with more house Judiciary Committee
chairman Jim Jordan is with us
Carling said that Weiss has always had
the authority to charge Hunter on a
under any circumstances anywhere
says Weiss never changed his story I
watched you contradict that in great
specificity and detail would you care to
go over that so everybody in America
that might have Mystic can hear it the
fundamental question is if he already
had the authority why does he need the
authority I mean that that to me makes
no sense but that's exactly what he
tried to say oh no he had it all along
but I still had to make him a special
counsel so I don't get it the three
letters they sent to us this summer two
to our committee one to Senator Graham
tell three different stories and the
point I always make is the story who's
been consistent has been the two
whistleblowers their testimony has not
wavered and they they were subjected to
about three hours across examination
from Democrats in the oversight
committee back in July never forget on
July 10th David Weiss tells Senator
Graham I have not sought special counsel
Authority then on August 11th the
Attorney General a general announces
that David Weiss will be a special
counsel what happened in those 32 days
what took place the whistleblowers came
forward with their testimony and the
plea deal that they were trying to sweep
everything under the rug the plea deal
is declined by a judge who did her job
and that's why we got a special counsel
they were going to get away with all
this but for those two Brave
whistleblowers and that judge in
Delaware who did her job let me ask you
you had a line of questioning with the
attorney general about the statute of
limitations and why the statute of
limitations left and why it was
important in the Years 2014 and 15.
these were the barisma tax years exactly
and then you gave four facts that I
think are critical uh regarding this can
you break that down for this audience
well the the facts are real simple fact
number 100 Biden gets put on the board
of Barista he gets paid millions of
dollars for those tax years 2014 2015.
fact number two he wasn't qualified to
be on the board in fact he said it not
me he said he got the position largely
because of his last name Devin archer in
his deposition said the brand was Joe
Biden the Biden name fact number three
the barisma executives asked Hunter by
can you help us we're under pressure
from the prosecutor can you help us
there's a call made to D.C fact number
four Joe Biden goes to Ukraine starts
the process and actually successful in
leveraging our tax dollars to fire the
very prosecutor who was putting the
pressure on barisma those facts are not
in dispute they are as solid as can be
and here's what's interesting that
fourth fact is exactly what the
confidential human source told the FBI
and the FBI recorded in the 1023 form
the same 1023 form Christopher Ray
didn't want to let Congress see those
said that it's all spelled out in there
so you got corroborating evidence that's
the pattern and then they let the
statute of limitations lapse expire
there's probably no one any person in
your audience that rocket studio
audience you have right now if they owe
hundreds of thousands of dollars
thousands of dollars
I bet the doj doesn't let the statute of
limitations lapse for them but they did
for the president's son because barisma
goes to the White House Joe Biden is
involved not on the gun charge they can
do that that doesn't involve Joe Biden
but on barisma it goes to Joe Biden let
me ask the fundamental question here as
Garland was pleading ignorance all day
long
does the attorney general not have to
sign up we had for the first plan was no
charges the second plan was okay we'll
do the slap on the wrist deal we'll put
in the plea agreement an immunity deal
and in the gun diversion portion of this
thankfully that judge caught that right
then plan C was oh I guess we're going
to have to indict him on the gun charge
but at least that still protects Joe if
Hunter has to be sacrificed he gets
sacrificed uh because he was pleading oh
no no Independence right for Weiss when
the Attorney General have to sign off on
whatever decisions are made here
well you would think particularly when
supposedly David Weiss goes and this is
a testimony we've got David Weiss goes
to the U.S attorney in the District of
Columbia and he declines to allow me to
prosecute there you would think the
Attorney General would weigh in then but
it looks like he didn't now he's
weighing in with the special counsel the
other thing I think is happening here in
this third plan I think the special
counsel allows them to extend this out
even further so we'll see what that all
means David Weiss is scheduled to be in
front of our committee on October 11th
they committed to have him come in front
of our committee I hope they will honor
their commitment chairman Jordan great
job today thank you for being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else